thanks uh so i also want to thank the
organizers and thanks to all of you for
sticking around until the bitter end
so what i want to talk to about today is
kind of a related
two related problems that are kind of a
particular
application where we want to do learning
so it's it's kind of in some ways very
similar to the last talk
but also in some ways a little different
because i am going to approach this
problem
more from a kind of statistical
estimation perspective
and a little bit less from the
perspective of computation and i
actually
i think there probably are uh very
important computational questions maybe
some of these already have answers but
uh
that's not exactly going to be the focus
so what i'm what i am going to talk
about is uh oh i guess
before i go further i should just
mention that the work i'm going to be
talking about is
is primarily the work of of my students
so andy
as a graduate student he's going to
graduate soon hopefully
and matt is actually an undergraduate
who's just starting
uh graduate school so okay so the
problem i want
to really focus on is this problem where
we want to estimate some vector say x
i'll think of x as just being a vector
in a k dimensional space uh and what
we're going to get to observe
are paired comparisons so the idea is
that
we're going to take our x and then we're
going to observe a bunch of comparisons
we say
okay i have these pairs i guess p
i and q i and what i'm going to get to
see is is
the x that i'm trying to estimate closer
to p i
or closer to qi which one of these two
things is is the closest so
uh the picture you should have in mind
is that i've got some
set of points and i know what these are
we'll talk about where they come from
later but
uh so i have these points these are what
we're going to be comparing against
and so we'll pick two of them and say
which one of them is closer to x
and so maybe in this case it was on this
side so
we kind of now have reduced our search
space
in some sense so now we pick another
pair of points and we can think about
repeating this process
until we have a pretty good idea of
where
where our point must live and okay so
the kind of question i'm going to be
interested in is how many
comparisons do we need to get certain
kinds of accuracy guarantees on
on how accurate uh or on uh you know
basically like the size of this region
or
or
if we have noise maybe there'll be some
other measure but basically how how
accurately can we estimate this point
just
from comparisons of this sort so there
are lots of places where this
uh comes up i'm going to focus just for
kind of organizing your thoughts and
having a concrete example in your mind
i'm going to focus on recommendation
systems as a
an example where this makes a lot of
sense because this idea of
of kind of having an embedding of points
and then saying
i want to know where some new point is
located with respect to those
existing points kind of falls out
naturally of
one of the very popular ways of
mathematically modeling
a person's preference so the idea is
that
uh i have a kind of a silly example here
that i think illustrates
a few points so imagine we looked at all
of the
drinks on the menu at like starbucks and
there are going to be more than two
features in reality but i'll assume that
we're only going to track
kind of two features one is how much
sugar has been added and one is how much
milk
has been added and so it kind of spans
the the space so some people
want coffee black some people want
things that just have incredible amounts
of milk added to it
and similar with sugar and so maybe uh
uh maybe if you looked at me i don't
this is not really true but
uh so maybe i like you know a little bit
of sugar added to it
and a lot of of milk and so we can kind
of think of
each individual as having some what's
called an ideal point
which kind of represents the ideal
combination of
features for them and then how much they
like an item
so how much i like these other drinks is
going to be basically proportional
in some sense to how far away that drink
is from
from my ideal point so this
this has a number of features that make
people kind of
like it so it is viewed as a more
powerful model than
uh what you may have may be more
familiar with if you know a little bit
about how
recommendation systems or the existing
literature on
recommendation systems a lot of it
focuses on
low rank matrix factorizations that
basically you can think of
uh all of the users and and items as
being you know you can represent their
prefer
the preference of every user for every
item as
uh some number in a matrix and then
uh we think believe there's some sort of
low rank factorization
of that matrix that we can use to
predict how how much a user likes an
item so what's kind of
lacking about that model is that it
basically if you think about it for a
while it induces
sort of a monotonic preference function
of all of the features so
uh basically you have this linear model
and so
if you happen to like one of the
features that you you learn out of this
factorization model then well how much
you like an item is going to increase
kind of without bound as more and more
of that feature
becomes present so i think in this kind
of a context it's sort of clear
that that probably doesn't make sense in
a lot of cases right so if
you know i maybe i like some amount of
sugar or some amount of
of milk in my coffee but it's certainly
not a monotonic function of how much
sugar you add like it there's definitely
a point where it becomes
uh becomes much worse than than having
maybe no sugar at all
um okay the other uh yeah i guess
i'll i'm sure so okay this is kind of a
uh
maybe a slightly cooked up example
uh but there are okay so recommendation
systems there are a lot of other
uh sort of more
common applications of recommendation
systems and
one thing that i kind of want to
emphasize is that right so in all of
this
the way i've been describing this
problem is we're going to get to see
which of these so you know we're trying
to learn this point and what we're going
to do is we're going to give
give me two different drinks and ask me
to taste them both and decide which one
i like
i like better so that's one way of
collecting feedback from the users you
could also ask me to give it a rating
people actually tend to not like to give
numerical ratings to things
so there's sort of some reason to be
biased towards actually directly
uh requesting these kinds of comparisons
where we explicitly ask people which of
these two things do you prefer
but i want what i want to kind of
emphasize is that you may not think
about it but these kinds of
paired comparisons are kind of
implicitly collected
in almost any website that you interact
with all of the time right so if you
think about how you use netflix so
netflix is always giving you
strange categories of and being like you
know so here's some movies
that share some common theme where they
come up with them is a little unclear to
me
so this is a screenshot not from me but
this is a
an actual movie category that netflix
has so this is movies with cool
mustaches i guess
and and uh
right so so when you are presented with
something like this
it may or may not be actually
personalized to you
but it is some list of uh movies and
when you're interacting with the website
you will see these movies and you will
click on some
or you you know you might hover your
mouse on it uh and you will probably
just skip over most
of them and so that kind of interaction
you know or if you're
if you do a google search or whenever
you're searching for items it's you know
you
they're presenting a list you select one
of them and so you do get this kind of
implicit uh paired comparison so you're
saying well this one is at least
somewhat more relevant to my interest
than the others
uh so i'll talk about this comparison
so yeah yeah so this is more than yeah
so one
and i'm not gonna uh i'm gonna focus on
kind of the simplest example where we
only have
two uh at a time you could think of this
as you know i guess we have six items
and so if
i actually selected one over the other
six you could think of that as saying
that's actually giving us like five
comparative paired comparisons
at once although there may be other
ways of thinking about that you're
getting right because it depends on
yeah so here we're in yeah yeah yeah
although they if you were netflix you
could control
what you present to people is your
choice of the successive pairs
adaptive or so we'll talk about that i
mean
i'll describe kind of what's possible
under certain model where they're not
adaptive and
we'll see that there are some
limitations in doing it that way and
that you can get
big gains by doing something adaptively
really you're working with the euclidean
metric here is that necessary
or is it ah i mean it's
i don't know that it is necessary but
yeah it's probably not
but yeah i don't know
there would definitely be some some
changes to to be made and
what i'm going to say here in a minute
yeah is the
existence of a finite list of possible
points important or could you phrase it
just in terms of selecting any
hyperplane you like
uh if you could select any hyperplane
you like
i think that uh it becomes an easier
problem so uh
but yeah we'll i think i'll i'll
kind of cover all of these in a little
bit more time so
um so briefly i am going to kind of
focus on
on this application sort of mentally
just to kind of keep this in mind
as a potential motivation there are
other
contexts where these kinds of
localization from these sorts of paired
comparisons
could be useful so i'll talk a little
bit later on about about non-metric
multi-dimensional scaling
which is just where you have a bunch of
points and you want to learn and
embedding into some
low-dimensional space based on
rather than so traditional
multi-dimensional scaling is where you
actually get to measure the distances
uh you have some sort of real value that
tells you how close points are
and in non-metric multi-dimensional
scaling that's where you
just have sort of ordinal statements
about which points are closest
to each other you know these these
points are closer to each other than
these other two points and
uh so some of what i have to say is
relevant there
um and then also you know i i haven't
really found a super compelling uh in my
mind application where
you actually just want to do this to
localize something in
physical space but that could be
i could i could imagine you know if you
didn't have gps there might be
some scenarios where you could uh
have some fixed set of beacons that you
know the locations of and you can
maybe it's easier to directly just
decide which one's closest as opposed to
actually measuring the distances yeah
yeah yeah although i think usually you
can get more information than just
which of these two things are closer so
if you can get more information you can
probably do better although
uh maybe not we'll we'll see um
okay so let me kind of state this
problem a little bit more mathematically
precisely so the in the problem i'm
interested in is how well we can
estimate
this this vector x uh and i want to kind
of contrast a little bit of what i'm to
say with
some existing results so there's a
there's a lot of literature on
um basically how do you learn a ranking
from comparisons of this sort some of
which so the most closely related
is worked by jameson and noak where they
looked at a very similar model where
you assume the points live in some low
dimensional space
and can argue that this gives you
kind of improved bounds in terms of
query complexity
how many of these comparisons do you
need to to do this although
so their their perspective is more of
like you want to just learn an ordering
of of the items
and i'm just going to be looking at this
from a slightly
different perspective which is actually
how well can we actually estimate this
this vector x so if you in some sense
you might be able to
you can relate the two of them but
they're not exactly the same thing
i'm going to assume throughout the the
talk that the
kind of uh so the only assumption i'm
going to make on x is that it's bounded
essentially that that it lives in a
euclidean ball of some
some radius otherwise i'm not going to
make any
structural assumptions on it like that
it's barce or
or has other kind of structure although
you could probably incorporate that if
you wanted to
and then my goal is going to be to say
okay well how many
of these paired comparisons do i need to
be sure that we can obtain an estimate
x hat that's say within epsilon of x and
i am going to be measuring this in the
euclidean norm
so okay so
one i guess one more thing i should say
before i kind of get to
the specific model i'm going to use this
is that there's kind of a nice compact
way of representing
these observations as single bits which
is to basically say
what we're going to do is we're actually
going to compute the sine of
the difference between these two
distances
or distances squared so in this case
it'd be 1
if we measure pi to be closer so this
distance would be bigger
than the other and then it would be
negative one if if q i was closer
and when we do this right so if if we
write out our model then
uh we realize kind of there's a lot of
cancellations that happen here
and you just go through the algebra uh
what you get is this
kind of expression here which uh
basically says okay if i look at the two
points
the the vector between them that kind of
tells us uh the direction
of uh so this is just a linear
measurement
we're gonna take x we're gonna project
it onto a vector in this direction
uh and then we have some threshold that
we add to that
and we get to observe this this single
bit
okay so i'll i think i won't
come back to this uh again but but
basically a much
kind of a simpler i'll just represent
this direction and threshold with
vectors a i and tau i and a number tau i
to keep things a little bit more compact
going forward
okay so so if we want to
talk about how well we can estimate x
it's it's kind of going to greatly
depend
on what these ais and tau i's look like
so if we have just a fixed set of points
we're going to have to pick
points to we're either going to have to
pick them
ourselves in some in some way
or we could yeah we could do things
adaptively or not adaptably but either
way we're going to be
somewhat limited in what kind of
directions we have
available to our just available to us
and what kind of towels we can
we can work with and so to get a rough
idea of what might be possible
i'm going to kind of assume that we
don't have a finite set of points
but have access to kind of
arbitrary choices for ai and tau
i and i think there are lots of things
you could actually do here
uh i'm going to analyze this problem
under the case where
uh the ais and the tau eyes uh are well
i guess where these are generated at
random
and the model that i'm going to use is
where basically the two points so we'll
just imagine to
get a feeling for what's possible that
these two points we're going to compare
to are generated
as iid gaussian random vectors
and see what happens so basically if we
do that you can kind of show that when
you appropriately re-normalize the
problem
what we're doing is we're taking x and
we're computing an inner product with
a vector that's uniform on the sphere
and then
we have some normal uh some
so it turns out this this offset is also
uh
a gaussian random or a gaussian number
uh and
the that the ai's and that this ai and
tau i are
independent of each other it was not
obvious to me for
quite a long time that these two things
are independent uh because they seem
like they
depend on a lot of the same things but
uh you can kind of
show that that's uh that's who i want
focus on why
so okay so this is basically the problem
that we have so if we assume this normal
model then what we're saying is
we want to estimate a vector x from
random observations
of this form and this has actually
already received a lot of attention in
recent years and in the context of
of what's called one bit compressive
sensing so
in one big compressive sensing basically
we have
some vector x typically it's actually
assumed to be a high dimensional vector
that's sparse
but you could apply all of these results
in the case where it's
it's just a low dimensional vector to
begin with
and you get these one bit observations
and you want to go from the observations
to get some estimate of of x
and the there's kind of uh two category
of
categories of results where people have
really looked at this
a lot so the first category is where
these ais are gaussian
or they could be uniform on the sphere
and then the towel eyes are zero
so there's no offset and so this was
kind of the first problem people looked
at and so there's a lot of
work on it but it's actually a really
hard problem
because when you think about what what
you could even say here
so if there's no tal i right you're only
observing these
the sign of these uh projections from x
onto
a hyperplane that goes through the
origin you're basically observing
which side of that these these
hyperplanes x
lands on and they all go through the
origin so
there's no way you could ever even say
anything about the normalization
of x you've completely lost any scaling
information right so you could multiply
x by a million it wouldn't actually
change any of your measurements
so there's kind of no way of getting
that piece of information back so
then you know people that kind of
earlier work on it was saying what we
need to do is we need to
just reconstruct something that lives on
the sphere but now i have
a non-complex optimization problem that
is hard to
work with there are convex optimization
problems that give
similar guarantees but they're all
stated in terms of sort of recovering
the angle uh that x has
but then kind of very recently there
there's been a little bit
of work uh where people looked at the
case where tau
i was not equal to zero uh and
uh so both of these papers i would say
that
there's kind of two messages that uh
i think are important so one is that
when when tau i
is not zero so if you now have this
additional degree of freedom
you can figure out what the scaling is
you're no longer limited
in terms of uh what's possible to say
about x you can just try to actually
reconstruct
x to high accuracy uh and the other
thing that kind of comes up especially
in this
second paper is that if you have this
additional freedom you can do something
potentially adaptive and get big
performance gains
and we'll see that something similar
happens uh in in our setup
neither of these sort of families of
results kind of directly apply they
don't they i can't just take
their theorems and apply them but kind
of similar
techniques uh can can be used
i'm not gonna focus on them i'll just
say what what we can say in the end so
suppose we we get m comparisons under
this model
uh and then what i'm going to do is i'm
going to pick a particular
variance for the sigma is the variance
that
uh is the the variance involved in
uh choosing the the points we're
comparing to so the p e and q
in our in our comparison model are
gaussian with this particular variance
and i'm setting it to be something
specific and saying that when we set
sigma when we set the variance
appropriately then what we can say is
that essentially for any
x hat that agrees with our observations
we have that x hat minus
x is less than epsilon with probability
at least one minus eta
i should have quickly changed it to
delta to agree with the last
talk so with probably at least one minus
delta provided that the number of
measurements we see is as
basically proportional to r over epsilon
times a factor that's basically
you know determined by the dimension and
a log factor
that's probably relatively uh tolerable
and
another log factor related to the
probability
yeah the threshold i think two slides
ago you showed that the threshold was
one over pi minus qi
or something another length
are really close together there's a huge
threshold yes it does so
so actually i'll i'll i have some i
think i have a slide in a minute that'll
give some intuition on that but yeah
that's
that is uh that issue is kind of is a
big part of why
i'm saying sigma squared is being set to
a particular level
because it's going to kind of prevent
this from
from being an issue i think
so okay yeah so in particular i say
right here okay so this proof
uh well it doesn't it's not the proof
falls apart it's still true but the
results
is kind of vacuous uh when
sigma squared is extremely when this
variance is extremely small
or extremely large and i think there's
some
some intuition for that uh and i'll show
that this
actually does happen in practice and
give some intuition in a second
uh let me just say i guess this theorem
is not really a statement about an
algorithm
this is just saying if you can find a
point that agrees with all of
your observations then uh it will be
good
there are lots of ways to try to
actually find one of these points
this is probably i won't say that there
that what i'm
doing is necessarily the best from a
computational perspective although it's
it's also very easy so what i'll do is
i'll assume
uh okay so uh basically
what i just said is that essentially if
m is sufficiently large
uh then any uh estimates that agrees
with our observations
and that has norm bounded then r will
will work so all we need to do is find
one of these
uh and a simple way to do it is to just
solve this
optimization problem that says find the
one with the smallest norm of everything
that agrees with these
observations yeah
so look at this expression does this
suggest that
when you have these kind of observations
generated this way
that if you're seeing them online let's
say they're coming in
is it that many times you're like oh
ah this alpha this threshold could be
useless
yes yes you kind of coupon collecting
until you
yes yes i think that's exactly yeah
yeah yeah something like that yeah i
think that that
yeah i think that is exactly what's
what's happening
um yeah
and i think this well okay so let me
show you
uh this this results here so
so um so if i use this
this approach i can look at how
accurately i estimate
in this uh model so i said that the the
bounce kind of suggested
that the variance was going to play some
important role
and when we look at sort of what kind of
reconstruction error we get
as a function of the variance we do sort
of see
that something real is happening that
there's
so this is a log scale i i guess i lost
the log but basically uh it turns out
that
that this level that i said was kind of
the right level
to set the variance is exactly where so
the theory suggests this is a good
choice and this is exactly where the
performance
tends to be best and i think the reason
why is is
kind of easy to understand if you think
about what's happening in these other
two cases so what happens if we set
the variance to be extremely small
so if they're very small that's that
basically means we're drawing points
from some gaussian density
that's extremely concentrated around the
origin so that's kind of the
the example that you were talking about
first so if all the points are
really close to each other and we're
saying okay we believe
our the point we're trying to estimate
lives inside of this sphere
and every com every pair of points that
we're comparing to is kind of like
at the origin so of every line
or all of our observations are just
going to look like this it's actually
reducing to this
this uh case where all the taus are
essentially
zero so i know you said they were really
big with us because i was
renormalizing everything in that formula
so in that kind of the
in the original formulation the taos
would all be very close to zero
um and so okay so we kind of know things
are going to be hard in this case
because all you're ever going to know is
kind of which slice
of the pie you you you lived in
the other case is maybe more like what
you were actually suggesting so if the
variance is very large
then uh it's going to be very likely
that most of the
of the hyperplanes that you generate
actually don't even intersect with
the region where you think your point
might live
right and so uh i think this kind of
suggests
that just choosing things according to a
gas intensity
i mean it might be okay for a while but
once you've been doing this for a while
you have enough information that you're
kind of in this situation where most of
the
these hyperplanes are probably not
giving you anything new
and it kind of suggests i think uh if
you're willing if you if you can
generate points according to this
gaussian density it suggests a very
simple adaptive scheme i think which uh
which should do better right so uh
basically what we're saying here
uh right so this is kind of a simpler
form of what we're
uh of what the result says we need to
we need to achieve basically uh all
right so the
i'm stating it in terms of of how many
measurements you need to get a recovery
error you could also say
right so how does epsilon decay as m
grows it's roughly 1 over m
and so to achieve very small errors m
you might have to think
would be very very large and so
we kind of know we should be able to do
better by doing something adaptive so
the approach that i'm gonna take is to
say well what if epsilon what if we just
set epsilon to be r over two so how many
measurements do we need in order to cut
our
uncertainty in half uh it doesn't really
matter here so this is what we have we
plug in
epsilon is r over two we just get some
number that
it's a constant except it depends on
that constant depends on the dimension
that we're
that we're in so it's bigger if we're in
a higher dimensional space
but if you just treat this as you know
this is some uh
some constant number of comparisons we
need to cut our error in half then you
could say okay well
after we've taken m naught comparisons
uh we've kind of cut our region of
uncertainty in half
right so we started here and then
after some constant number of
comparisons so m not comparisons we have
some new some estimate that we can
produce
and now we can say okay actually well we
know
that with high probability the true x
has to
live within this this radius and so now
we could still generate points from this
gaussian density
but centered on this point and with a
smaller variance
and if you can continue continue doing
this you get a much faster
rate of convergence uh much quicker
estimate
right so what i kind of like about this
approach i guess i say
what it is here so this is just in words
what i just described
uh so what is nice about this okay is
that if we have some fixed
number of measurements so m uh
i'm going to assume that m is you know
some factor bigger than how many
measurements it takes to
cut the error in half so we run this for
m over m naught iterations
uh and the reconstruction error is going
to basically decay exponentially
fast and that and that number in
contrast to just
one over the square root of m in the
general case so
what i like about that about this
approach is that it's very easy even
though it's all
uh stated in terms of gaussian random
vectors
it's very easy to adapt it to the case
where you actually have
just some fixed set of points to choose
from there are lots of different ways
you could think about
about doing that so the simulation that
i'm showing here is actually
doing this where there's just a fixed
embedding of points and what
what the what we're doing is we're
picking things from a gaussian density
and then just kind of
you know from those two points what's
the closest element in my point set
to each of them uh there are probably
other ways you could
use important sampling or do something
else this is just the first thing
that occurred to us and and one thing i
just want to kind of point out is you
get
you do sort of see even in that case
where you have a finite set of points
we're picking from you do see this big
gap that after a while you really the
rate of improvement
by doing something non-adaptive really
slows down
but by introducing this adaptive you get
bigger sort of a faster convergence to
whatever the best you could do is at
some point
so we don't continue the simulation uh
much past this because
if you have a finite set of points to
pick from at some point you kind of hit
a resolution limit
where you can't really do any better
given
given those points okay so i'm i think
i'm basically out of time so i'll skip
this i'll just say one thing i liked
about the
the reason why we thought about this
from the perspective of solving this
convex optimization problem
is that it's extremely simple to make it
robust to
to noise right so if you have some
errors you just
kind of introduce some slack variables
and get something that looks like an svm
and then it's pretty easy to to work
with
uh one okay so i have just a couple
slides here
um i guess
is it okay if i keep going since i don't
see uh david i'll just talk for the next
30 minutes
uh no so so um so if i go back
to this problem so i've been talking
almost exclusively about localizing like
basically we get measurements like this
and we want to know what x is we want to
fit a user
into this so like if we have some mature
recommendation system we have some
embedding of all of the
items and we just have some new user
we're trying to figure out where they go
but you could also imagine a situation
where you get a new item
so there's some new movie you're going
to add to this embedding and you just
maybe you don't have any other
information about it that you really
trust and you want to just use
these user comparisons to figure out
where where it goes
uh so you might think that the that it's
kind of a similar problem it turns out
that if these are the observations that
you're getting this
and you're trying to think of say you
know
i guess x and q y so you know some the
user where the user is and you know
where the other point is and you want to
estimate
pi this is giving you a very different
kind of
information so if y y i is one you're
basically saying
that p i lives inside of a sphere of
some given radius
but if y i is negative one it's actually
that it lives outside of a sphere
of a certain radius and so this is kind
of a this is fine actually but this is a
an ugly constraint to work with and so
there are lots of things you might be
able to do but
we realized kind of shortly after
realizing this was the case that there's
a sort of a simple
way to convexify this problem
by basically involving looking at pairs
of comparisons
the only trick is we need different
users
and if we have two different users that
have both compared this
this item uh p to two points these don't
need to be the same
so q1 and q2 could be totally different
and
where p is landed on sort of opposite
sides of those two inequalities
uh then you can kind of basically just
add those two
inequalities together you get a linear
uh
a linear constraint uh the picture is
basically that
so this this is useful sometimes to do
so the picture that i have in mind is
that
uh you thought you so this is the
constraint that says i live inside of a
sphere
then i live outside of this one so the
constraints that i'm working with is
this weird pac-man
shape and what this process is doing is
basically saying
i'm just going to linearize this
seemingly throw away a ton of
information
but it turns out you know there are so
many of these kinds of constraints that
when you combine them it
works pretty well you can use the exact
same algorithm you can get similar
results
um and so uh yeah so i was gonna
kind of mention with this now that if we
can actually do both users and items
separately
there's sort of a simple way of using
this to do really large scale
multi-dimensional non-metric
multi-dimensional scaling and
the algorithm is to basically do
something kind of sophisticated like
solve a semi-definite program
to uh learn the location of some
core set this is not a core set this is
like
that's why i've been quotes so i just
mean like some subset of the users and
items
and then once you have a kind of a good
representative subset of all of them you
can kind of just
localize all the remaining users and
items one at a time
using this approach and maybe iterate if
you want
uh and we actually looked at just
ignoring this first step
altogether and just choosing a random
starting point and kind of iterating
over all of them and even that actually
works surprisingly well so
okay so i won't even i won't i'll just
go ahead
and finish um there any questions maybe
i'll
field those while david gets set up
in computational geometry there's this
idea of arrangements of hyperplanes and
how many cells they produce and so on
right and basically what you're doing
your fixed set of points
is considering the arrangement formed by
all the bisecting
points and asking yourself what cell is
your x located in
what you're asking yeah so there's both
kind of combinatorial
results to talk about the number of
cells that can be created by n
hyperplanes and
maybe yeah yeah queries you need to
converge on the cell i mean to zoom in
on the cell i don't know yeah so what
i'm not
familiar with is uh
is how you would say something so if
you're just given
a fixed set of points and you want to
know like it seems to me like
if you wanted to get a uniform result
that says no matter where x is in this
space
i can get a good estimate of x
i don't know it seems like you'd have to
make some additional assumptions
on the properties of that set of points
and i guess i haven't
come across anything that kind of does a
good job
but yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah but i do and maybe i was not super
clear at this at the beginning but like
i do think that there's probably
algorithmically a lot a lot there right
so if you
you know people must have looked at this
at this kind of problem
before from uh maybe not trying to
understand it from this
perspective of how big is the diameter
of the
kind of largest cell that's formed but
certainly like just
finding x very efficiently and in real
time that's probably
you know locating the person versus
locating the item thing was interesting
investigation ideas cool the question i
had was
do you have a sense whether one of them
is actually higher quality information
like you might be not it might not be
convex it might be but is it
actually more informative i think it is
yeah yeah
so and in fact we found that even when
we
so when we did this convexification uh
and i don't really have a good
intuition for this but like it seemed
like we actually needed fewer
comparisons
to get a good localization of the item
it's probably on the order of a constant
i mean i don't
but it actually that that works better
than localizing the user even after
we've done this
convexification process which is
throwing away tons of information
so i do think that there might be i
don't know how to
exploit that do you think it changes the
scaling do you have this kind of one
over
could be possible maybe
yeah i don't know
questions